[Music]
what's up squirrel
you sleep all right
no
we got to get going seriously she won't
stop kicking come on
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
in a perfect world none of this ever
would have happened
androids were a part of our everyday
life for hot chocolate
and then one night
everything changed
we've gotta get to boston before i give
birth
it's the only safe place
how long would that take two
you can weeks a safe way for us to go
i'll go
i'm fighting a war against an enemy that
literally never sleeps
killing machines they won't stop so
we're all dead
we gotta get through no man's land
without being noticed
no checkpoints
no humans
a lot of androids
would have to be quiet
silent
i'd have to be silent
we cannot run them this is the only shot
we've got
an android rebellion leads to the
extinction of human life
i would kill for you i would die for you
that would be the same for our baby
my son i'm going to give you the only
thing that i have left
a chance
[Music]
you